Obama called Lula one of the best  politicians in the world and he was on  Time Magazine 2010 when the top 100 most  inflation men in the world that's Lula  we're talking about he knows how to  Market himself he knows how to sell  himself and he knows how to play the  game he's been around for a very very  long time playing this game he's a pro  amongst Pros to pin who against who he  knows how to talk to the Evangelical and  kind of persuade them he's he is he is  the credit goes to him as a strategist I  don't agree with his policies I don't  agree he has the world Community he has  his side and then the other part with  China he's not as smart as you think you  just have he just has a lot of energy is  not necessarily smart to me strategy is  wise to me smart is intellectual  educated degrees you you do not want to  go against a wise competitor